hey youtubers is Charlie so during my
arrow district review I asked you to
submit all of your WTF questions about
Isabel Ravager
Slade's plans and the rest of the season
so I picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question if you're
finding me for the first time I
typically do Q&A videos for all my
favorite shows like Doctor Who Game of
Thrones you know anything that's worth
doubling down on just because it's so
much fun to talk about so feel free to
leave me any suggestions for future
bonus arrow videos in the comments we've
only got a few more episodes left before
the finale so time for questions let's
talk our way through the WTF fest that
was destro califor full potential
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet but question number one comes from
Slade Wilson himself and he asks there
are some new images of Summer Glau
dressed in a costume like Slade's do you
think that she's secretly Rose Wilson or
is she just Isabel dressed as ravager so
that was actually a very good question
because there were some images that
posted really early Thursday morning and
she basically is dressed like rose
Wilson is ravager the images do look
legit but based on the information we
have right now we cannot say that she's
rose outright but we can't call her
ravager they might just be messing with
the character a little bit arrow has
been pretty faithful to the comics like
when Billy wintergreen Ward the
Deathstroke masked they didn't call him
Deathstroke you know they waited and
gave that to Slade Wilson but if it
looks like ravager and it fights like
ravager it probably is ravager Isabel
rochev in the comics did have a history
with Oliver's father and there's a
theory that she was that woman you see
off screen in season 1 you know with the
red shoes the comic book character was
also involved in a plot to use Queen
industries to make a super soldier army
so until the show presents us with some
more information let's just say she's
Isabel as ravager not rose Wilson
ravager real mystery on the show is is
Summer Glau history with Slade Wilson
and how they started working together
question number 2 McLovin asks do you
think that the Suicide Squad Merlyn and
team arrow will have to team up to beat
team Deathstroke
so I definitely think the Suicide Squad
is going to get involved after that you
know in teaser during the Suicide Squad
episode with Amanda Waller
as for Merlyn you know John Barrowman
did just tweet that he was back in
Vancouver for filming
he didn't confirm that it was for arrow
but they are filming the finale
now and they're almost done so it seems
like he won't be back till episode 23
Merlin is really only in it for Thea so
the only way he'd fight with team arrow
is if he was trying to defend her we do
know that Slade's army will be going
crazy all over the city in episode 22
Streets of Fire so it's possible that
something could happen to Thea and it
would compel Merlyn to help Oliver I
actually really hope that this ends up
happening because not only do I love
John Barrowman he's just an amazing
actor I love it when villains end up
having to work with heroes you know
bitter enemies working together for a
common goal it just makes for a really
great storytelling question number three
Tim asks do you think that Roy will have
his own dark Tinkerbell do you think the
Thea might become Artemis and do you
think that Slade's army of super
soldiers will receive super powers or
they'll be just like Slade and Roy so
lots of questions so I'll try and keep
my answers short
Roy's Tinkerbell would totally have to
be Thea it would just be amazing Thea is
Artemis I think is a little further off
I think the next big character shift
we'll see is Laurel becoming the Black
Canary no idea if that's gonna happen in
season 3 but it all depends on whether
or not Katie Lots dies in the finale
she's listed in the credits on the wiki
for episode 22 Streets of Fire but we
still don't know anything about what's
happening in the finale as for the super
soldiers they'll just be like Slade and
Roy mirakuru just enhances your own
natural abilities so if the criminals
weren't good fighters before mirakuru
isn't gonna magically turn them into
ninjas just think of them is like a
super-strong infantry Slade is basically
just gonna like shoot them like a
shotgun at the city just like spread
fire all over the city question number 4
galaxy ronan asks do you think the
Deathstroke is getting all his funding
from hive yeah that hive teaser during
the russia episode was a really big deal
but we haven't heard a lot about it
since they were the ones that hired dead
shot to kill diggle's brother and
Deadshot implied that it was because
Biggles brother was into something
really shady with hive no idea what
that's all about yet but I do think that
that plot with hive might be something
that will factor into season 3 in one of
my previous Q&A is I actually listed a
bunch of potential villains for season 3
and hive was at the top of the list
more on hive though in the comics Slade
Wilson's former wife was one of the
founding members there's also queen bee
but we haven't learned anything about II
of those characters recently so hi this
still a mystery I would guess that slate
at least has ties to them he's probably
not running high but he's probably using
hive in the same way that Oliver uses
Argos in the Suicide Squad question
number five courageous asks do you think
that brother blood might be Jericho I
actually saw a lot of comments about
this because of the Isabel Ravager
teasers after the implication that
Isabel might be secretly Rose Wilson and
Slade's daughter a lot of people thought
that maybe brother blood might also be
Slade's son secretly but remember in the
asylum brother Bloods real-life mother
talked about him killing his real-life
father when he was little so I think
that Slade is just using blood as a
means to an end that final scene with
them together kind of made it seem like
Slade has been withholding a lot of
critical information from him so don't
be totally surprised if Slade throws him
to the wolf so to speak in the finale or
sometime before that
question number 6 Dragon animations asks
do you think that Thea could become a
villain so in the real world of the show
no I don't think so Thea is always going
to be part of the team arrow but I do
think that she could become Roy's evil
Tinkerbell like shadow is - Slade I
would really like to see her get
involved in the action she's kind of
been on the sidelines most of the season
but she does become a big part of
episode 20 so look forward to that
question number seven Funko Saurus nice
name
asks for episode 20 seeing red do you
think it's gonna be a flash crossover or
about Roy as he gets mad initially when
they announced the title I actually
thought it was gonna be a flash
crossover and it was gonna be the
backdoor pilot it was gonna be like an
all flash episode but they basically
changed that whenever they gave flash
its own one-hour pilot when everything
got changed they basically made episode
19 a crossover with killer frost and
vibe you know the flash characters and
now we know that episode 20 is all about
Roy he basically loses his and team
arrow just has to deal with him he gets
super violent and Sarah wants to kill
him remember she's that same person that
wanted to suicide bomb Slade on the
island she's super dark Oliver and Thea
tried to talk him down you know he ends
up hurting Thea and Oliver supposedly
opens up a can of whoop-ass no idea how
they talked him down or how that's gonna
play out
but it's all about them dealing with Roy
after he starts to go really really
crazy like Slade part of the conceit
with Sara trying to put him down you
know like she did in episode
is that she thinks he's uncurable she
thinks there's no way to fix mirakuru
madness I think that whatever their
solution is to Roy's problem is gonna be
very important for how they deal with
Slade in the finale it seems like the
only way to completely fix Roy would be
to counteract the effects of the
mirakuru so maybe they'll either find a
way to get Miroku out of this system or
find a way to you know use STAR Labs to
create some sort of mirakuru anti rage
pills question number eight trace blonde
asks do you think that Amanda Waller is
going to use Roy is Arsenal in the
Suicide Squad no I think that after they
fix Roy you know so to speak then he'll
continue to roll with team arrow Amanda
Waller mostly just works with convicts
whatever comes to the Suicide Squad like
full-on supervillains she might get
involved though in episode 20 when they
try to deal with roid rage Roy trying to
say that three times fast question
number nine Stephen Casey asks how about
when Felicity told Oliver go get Thea
and kill Slade I actually think that's a
really important line it really defines
Felicity's relationship with Oliver
she's like his lightning rod
Oliver is supposed to be their leader
everyone looks to him for guidance so he
has to have someone that can provide him
with some clarity and that's felicity so
family aside you could say that felicity
is the most important person on Team
arrow because she keeps Oliver from
going crazy question number 10 Ryan asks
based on the preview for episode 19 do
you think the team arrow will break into
STAR Labs to get some type of technology
to use against Slade yeah based on the
clip it looks like Sara comes up with an
idea to borrow something from STAR Labs
it would also seem that that's the back
door for the flash characters to come on
the show it's Caitlin snow and Cisco
Ramon two researchers working at STAR
Labs in the timeline of events on arrow
this is all happening in real time
you know since the accident so it's been
a couple months since the particle
accelerator exploded and gave Barry
Allen those powers we don't know if or
when snow will become killer frost or
Cisco will become vibe it would be
awesome if it happens in this episode
but as quickly as the stories move in
these hour-long episodes I feel like
they're gonna save that kind of stuff
for the actual flash TV show in the clip
Cisco is firing a really big weapon so
that could be what they're trying to
steal but STAR Labs is full of
fun toys and tech and one last bonus
question James Thomas asks do you think
that the death of a character will be
what brings team arrow back together so
you are talking about an agent coulson
Avengers moment there have been a lot of
events recently that suggest that might
happen like suicide bomber Sara Laurel
Black Canary teases Moira and detective
Lance talking about not being able to
take the pain of losing people something
just tells me that team arrow will be
fixed again before the finale I don't
think they'll do a straight up copy of
what happened in Avengers but I do think
that someone will die in one of those
last two episodes it just feels like the
plot has been building towards that kind
of moment but everyone be sure to let me
know who you think is gonna die and
thank you so much everyone for
submitting your questions these bonus
Q&A videos are so much fun to do I'm
actually working on a new type of bonus
video for Game of Thrones and if it
works I'll start doing it for arrow and
all the other Big Show's too it's gonna
take a little bit of work to figure out
but I'll keep you guys posted so like I
said arrow is gonna be on break next
week so I'll be doing a bonus video be
sure to subscribe to get it and leave me
suggestions for what you want to see in
that in the meantime you can click here
to get my top 10 WTF moments from the
episode and you can click here to get my
Winter Soldier review thanks so much
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you